well let's bring in our next guest it's
San Diego County Supervisor Jim Desmond
Jim it's great to have you it's such a
terrible topic um it's just
heartbreaking what is happening we know
that since Joe Biden's um policies have
come into place over 85,000 children
have been lost in our system many of
them falling into sex slavery and sex
trafficking essentially uh have has the
Biden Administration reached out to you
where we know a lot of this is happening
through San Diego uh have they reached
out to you have they shown any curiosity
as to how their policies are driving
young girls um and some boys in into
this sex
slavery no they have not reached out to
us at all and it's very you know
terrifying that you know th this is
going on here in San Diego County we're
like in the top 13 places in the country
for uh sex trafficking and and human
trafficking and it's primarily because
of the proximity to the the Border I
mean if we didn't have open porous
borders and the cartels weren't
controlling our gangs here on this side
of the Border I think we'd be in a lot
better shape so the only reaching out
we've been doing is is saying hey would
you please close our borders would or
would you please give us some money to
manage the number of people that are
being dropped off here in San Diego
County we've had over 83,000 migrants
dropped off in San Diego County over the
last four months it's like 20,000 a
month and a lot of these people are
being set traffic being brought across
the border this is their payment to the
cartels for being brought across the
border and and so this this has not been
they have not reached out to us and and
it's a tragedy and we do not want this
moniker for our you know tourist area
here in Southern California no we just
don't want to have any complicity as a
nation in this Scourge I mean it's just
unbelievable you know the government as
well as the NOS who by the way are
getting very rich off of this entire
policy very very rich it's something we
need to talk more about but they know
that many of these girls are as as you
know young as 10 11 12 13y olds are
being loaded up with birth control pills
prior to making this journey because
they know they're going to get raped and
then once they get here many of them
again as you said as a payment um their
families are are are letting them fall
into this or they're being kidnapped
along the way and and given to these
gangs um who are being controlled by the
cartels I what kind of resp
responsibility what can be done to hold
not just our federal government and Joe
Biden accountable for what is happening
to these children but also these ngos
who are encountering these kids um I I
I've been by the way Jim to to some of
these child facilities uh detention
facilities they treat it's like a prison
no media no uh not even congressmen are
allowed to go in and see what's going on
um it just seems like they know what's
happening and they're hiding it and it
just seems so evil and so so
unbelievable well and and this is you
know just like fentol this is another
thing that's coming across our open
borders you know why are we continuing
to allow this and and Biden
Administration just seems to turn a
blind ear to this and it's just really
affecting you know not just san dieo
county anymore the border border
communities but also New York and
Chicago and other areas so I mean we
really got to get get a handle on this
and you can't blame people for coming
across we've got we give them free
healthcare we give free education in San
Diego County we even pay if if a um an
immigrant is being deported we pay for
their legal fees my Democratic
colleagues voted that in that we're pay
even if they just beat up a cop or they
just murdered somebody or they have
somebody in human trafficking we are
paying their legal fees if they're being
deported it's just crazy what's going on
I really think you know it all comes
down to our border policies let's stop
the human trafficking the sex
trafficking the fentol all of these
things can can be con managed if we just
get a hold of and and close our border
and and open it up to to Legal migrants
coming in in instead of just letting
everybody through yeah I mean where are
the religious organizations many of them
many of the churches are part of these
NOS they're making money knowing that
this is happening and where the heck are
the women's movement um it's just
obvious right now um they're absent they
don't care um they care about abortion
rights but not about little girls that
are being trafficked um and little boys
across the AC Ross the Border um and our
government is totally complicit in this
uh Jim I can't thank you enough for
coming on this is a topic we don't talk
enough about I know it's hard in the
morning um to hear this for those of our
viewers but it's important thank you
Jim thanks Rachel I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kill me and I'm Angley airheart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis